So that's a good question. Like how do people usually get into PM?
I tried to get into PM. Did you know that I tried to get into RPM,
Facebook or APN, like Google, I didn't get those roles,
but then if you don't get those roles, how do you get into debt?
So I think there's two. Yeah.
There's two ways that I think like people can get into product, right?
Like one is like join a program where it's like, there is no,
there's no prerequisite for how much experience you have.
So like all the big companies have rotational programs and product.
The problem is, is there's like, because there's no prerequisites,
there's 20,000 people applying for 10 slots, right? It's just like,
it's like almost like harder to get into the college and to get into these roles
and everything into college.
Before we continued as video. I just want to say,
thank you so much to air table for sponsoring this video air table allows people
and companies to create their own custom applications,
regardless of their technical skills,
millions of people use air table to build their own custom software use cases,
ranges from product management to major video productions.
So that means that air table can be an all in one platform for product
managers.
What would you make if you had to tools designed for the weight you like to
create air table gives you the freedom and structure to design a workflow that
fits your needs. Air table can handle all kinds of content that you throw at it.
Attachments long text posts, checkboxes,
and just so much more with air table, you and your team can ideate, organize,
and execute on your ambitious product vision all in one place,
quickly glance at a high level progress on all your initiatives or drill down to
any specific details and understand how to unblock your projects.
Air table is an all in one collaboration platform that keeps up with even the
fastest growing product teams. Now, if you're interested,
you can receive $50 of credit by signing up on air
table.com/joma. All right.
Have you ever used air table before?
I have, I actually, I, when I was working on box,
when she worked with really irritate the build integration, we had how he,
the CEO come in and talk at our Friday lunch. Um,
but in general I was on the company. It was really small,
but now it's like been growing like crazy.
Yeah. Welcome to the show, man. It's been a while.
Yeah. All right.
So I brought you in today because you're a product manager at Fang,
right. So why don't you just give me a short introduction of yourself? Yeah,
so I saw Andre, um,
I've been about a PM for maybe four or so years.
I studied, I grew up in, on the bark. I studied, uh, management,
science and engineering at Stanford, did a couple of startups, uh, during,
when I was interning. Um, so I did one at a company called Smule,
which is a social music company, um,
most famous for the IMT pain app on the phone,
the first one to use the microphone as, um,
an instrument to second hour, put a company called like reputation.com,
which was more of like a privacy type company.
They did a little bit of kind of more data analytics type work. Um,
and my junior year, I decided I wanted to just see what SMA was all about,
uh, and sold out for a little bit and did a summer.
I had been invested in anymore. Stanley.
Is that when you started falling arbitrage and yeah. Babies? Um,
I definitely understand those jokes, but I just realized at that point,
I just wasn't necessarily kind of right. For me. Um,
there was a lot of like client service type work.
So you already worked on behalf of someone else instead of building your own
things yourself. And based on my other jobs,
I always realized that like becoming,
being a PM is all about like building things and I wanted to get back to
building things.
And so that's kind of where I was and I was kind of the goal I wanted to get to
is like, how do I start building and having to go to PM?
So the first PM job would be where, yeah,
first I'm job I had was at box, but I didn't start as you know.
And then your second PM job is at Facebook. Okay. Nice. Nice.
Who have you worked with at Facebook? I've worked with Jomo.
Jomo was my data scientist at Facebook. He was one to 10.
He got stuff done. You can say the truth. I'll just edit all the bad stuff.
Okay. So I'm just going to stick to the script this time,
because a lot of people tell me that I talk too much during these interviews and
you're like, shut the up. Joma I'm going to stick to the script. Alright. Okay.
So what does it feel like to be silicon's Valley's most eligible guy
and you you're speaking those words out, man. No, it's true.
All my viewers are like, Oh my God. All right.
Let's get to the real penal stuff. So yeah.
So you told me that he did IB investment backing and then you switched to
PMO right before ID. You were killing it there. Yeah. Yeah.
I did a ton of things. It was mostly worked. It's tech startups. Yeah.
Was box the first full time job you started out. Okay.
So you were at the house? Yeah. So I actually did a lot of steps,
but there's a lot of different things at box.
I joined the team that was like a step within box. I did like,
I did develop a marketing. I did partnerships, data analytics.
I did comms to such a phase. It was a small team.
Everyone had to kind of work on everything from box office as a small company
and the team within.
So I helping build out our developer platforms C and so it was like probably
five or six people within that, whereas our own business unit.
So I ended up doing kind of all the ranges of work just based on what we
needed. Um, but wasn't, and I did product stuff, but I wasn't a product manager,
but at the end you were product within.
So what I did was I knew I wanted to do it,
but I guess if you have is in general, it's like, there aren't that many roles,
especially for people that are coming without a PM experience. Yeah.
So that's a good question. Like how do people usually get into PM?
I tried to get into PM. Did you know.
I tried to get into RPM, Facebook or APM, like Google,
I didn't get those roles, but then if you don't get those roles, how do you get?
Yeah. So I think there's two. Yeah.
There's two ways that I think like people can get into product, right?
Like one is like joining a program where it's like, there is no,
there's no prerequisite for how much experience you have.
So like all the big companies have rotational programs with product.
The problem is, is there is like, because there's no prerequisites,
there's 20,000 people applying for 10 slots. Right. It's just like,
it's like almost like harder to get into the college and to get into these roles
that it is going into college.
Do you know the numbers for RPM APM acceptance?
Uh, no. I think just in terms of sheer numbers, like I would imagine,
like how many does the Facebook hire? I think it's around like 14, 14,
14 to 20, maybe every year or per quarter. Uh,
I think it's almost per maybe increase more, but when I first started,
I was like 14 per year. That's great. And so if you think about it, it's like,
it's like just the numbers aren't in your favor to start in a way that like a
lot of people have done it in a way that I tell people that they want to get
into product is like, there's two other pathways. One is like,
you work at a company in another role and then build up your kind of background,
all of your reputation of the company and then transition it,
transitioned laterally in the company to product. If there is an opening,
just because everyone knows that you're a known quantity.
People know if you're doing well,
like they're more likely to define the product role. And the second one is like,
you can probably try to find a really small startup and start to just do other
things, including product. Um, but I would say the easiest way,
but also it's not the most direct way is to do it within a company that
transition in that product role. Right. Um, and then once you are at once,
you are like, uh, in the product role, it becomes,
it opens up a lot of pathways because you have some experiences.
Immature. So before becoming a PMO,
what are the best jobs to transition into PMs?
And this is not me knocking any of like the rotational programs,
but if you start as a PM right out of college, like it's great.
You become a really good PM,
but you're really focused on doing something the first way you learned it.
Right? So if you work at Google, you work at Facebook,
but you learned to do a PM's job that way. And that's what your role,
what you think of PM. Or we think of other functions, then you can be a good PM.
But I think to become like a really great PM, which I think I'm still working,
working towards is it's almost like it's, it's definitely more,
I would encourage people to go work in other functions that are that help
support product anyways. Like they could be analytics, it could be marketing,
it could be communication could be sales, right.
And you build empathy around like how other people work with products.
So when to become a product manager,
you understand how all these other functions tie together to become like a
really, really good product manager that sees the whole picture. Right.
Instead of just a narrow piece of building product. Right.
But I think like in general, there is no real like, like stepping stone.
I don't think there really is.
I think like hands on with the skills that you want,
it's been one depends on the company brighter,
but it depends also depends on the skills that you want to develop as a PM.
Cause there's so many different types of things.
That's true. Like 1:00 PM can,
can totally have a different skillset than another one.
If you want to be a super technical.
PM, like yeah. It might be really helpful to have it sweet. You might. Yeah.
You might have, if you're a software engineer, you work in data,
like it'd be really helpful to get really nitty-gritty with technical details.
But if you're doing something that's more like consumer facing or a little bit
abstracting away,
like having communicate good communication skills and being able to problem
solve and think deeply about a problem is even more important.
So it doesn't matter where like what job you had before. Um,
I think the one thing to note is like, you don't like,
I I've taken computer science classes. Like I understand like how to code,
but by no means I am technical.
And so like some of the best teams that I know are,
have no technical backgrounds and they just learn.
And they're curious about like diving deep and understanding a problem that
like, it doesn't matter if they're don't right. Okay.
But if you had to choose like one job that is the easiest to transition into PM,
let's say at Facebook, because since you're there for awhile,
like which shop do you see most often in general? Let's see. I mean,
software engineering, you see, there are three types of,
I think you got to do software engineers too. Yeah.
There's some software engineers that turn into PMs if they don't, if,
if they want to start like building things and managing people,
I don't think it's super common. I think data,
people who are dating and data, um, data analytics, data science,
like having a herring grasp of like data and how it's used our decisions.
So I think it's in there, you see a lot of people that transition.
I twin I have a twin brother that's also a PM would do the 4:00 PM.
He was an analytics scientist. Um, and for them it's easy.
Cause you can see the data trends. So you're at least, you know,
how to dig apart and form hypothesis.
The other one is I think even if you're in product marketing, right?
Like you're so close to the product that like you understand customer needs.
So if you're really empathize empathy with the customer or their user,
like it's much easier to become a PM because you already have that
understanding. That's true because it's so hard to kind of, um,
rate different PMs because you're saying like every PM does really different
things. So what makes like good Pampers is a great pan, like you said. Yeah.
I think it gives, you know,
someone that can just execute well on like the vision, right?
Like you have a roadmap, you execute you on block. Um,
and you just marched towards like your level.
I think a great PM does a couple of things.
One can help like really strategize around what is the next thing that's coming.
So think ahead of the box. So like if you plan in like six months,
like you're working towards that six month, good line.
But you're also understanding like in the next six months of what do we indeed
build? And so you're always thinking ahead of how these products can,
that can scale further.
I think the second thing is around like just communication.
I think if you can communicate and set context,
Cod different contexts settings across like all the different functions,
like engineering and product marketing privacy, right?
Like I think it makes a light you're like really easy to unblock your team. Um,
and getting under people buy and understand why you're doing something. Um,
and I think the last thing it's always really helps to be really fluid and data
and understand like, honestly, with writing your own queries,
it's great to write your own queries if you can. But, um,
I didn't do anything with, I had a piano. I did it myself.
It was great with data. So you see something go up,
you have to understand why it goes up and being able to break apart and
understand exactly why the, with the lovers are,
it makes you just really develop good product intuition to understand like,
this is why these things are happening. Cause then it's like, ah,
it's just luck. And then it can help reinforce what you want to do.
So even as a good PM, you know, you say you have to execute well, but it's,
it's kind of hard to, I at least for some people to grasp, what,
what does it actually mean to execute like their day, right? Like what,
like why is it hard to execute? You just ask someone to do something,
ask someone to do for it's easy, right? Or is it it's actually, I mean,
I would assume it's easy there, but as you're working, you're not working,
you're going to run functions or you're a design or with engineering,
you're going to data.
You don't need the research and eat for each project that you have potentially,
you might have different asks for each of them. Right.
And so for maybe your scope, you're starting out a project,
you need research and design to start like lead the way before you can help
scope out some family engineering side.
And so it was getting the timelines and land to like understand what the
sequencing of every project is to make sure everyone's getting their deadlines.
And so it's making sure different teams work together so that each team has what
they need in order to go build the product. And then once people are building,
it's like, there's always the roadblocks that come up.
And then it's how you unblock that to you. If it's working with another team,
it's like,
how do you get that team to do what you want and unblocking your team so they
can continue to execute. So like, it's a lot of like people management skills,
but also just like a lot of like trying to influence, um,
to get things done. Yeah. Get done.
So as a great product manager, like you are,
are there any like anecdotes or actually a concrete things like tips
that you can give to product manager on how to influence people or how to, uh,
align people to better? Yeah. I think that'd be,
I think the bigger thing is like, it's how do you set shared goals? It's like,
if you have your team is working on one thing and another team is working on
another thing. Like if those goals are not aligned,
like people are not going to work together.
And so it's framing a problem saying like, this is the goal we're trying to do.
This is how it helps you. This is how,
what you're doing helps us make sure that like everyone's like aligned and
incentivized or work on the same thing. When those things don't work.
Then like you always have this fight of trying to like escalate it and say, Oh,
this, this, like, this seems not doing what we want them to do.
And it becomes contentious.
And so I think it's more about how do you operate a good working model,
get people bought in to light and what the success is and say it upfront what
the success is to make sure. And then align like commitments.
They get people to actually like do things on time.
Cause everything requires a lot of work across different teams,
kind of a niche question. But what do you think matters more, uh,
relationships with these different teams to make them do stuff or
incentives? Uh, I think they go with the hand in hand.
I think that like you can't say one or the other,
I think incentivizing a team through like the right shared goals builds helps
build your relationship. Um, cause, um, I mean, when I was a data scientist,
I did a lot of favors to PM's that like more that's it like?
So it's not necessarily incentives. I feel like,
I don't know if incentives work as well on me than like relationship.
I'm sure it's different for me if we were to say, but if you were to say like,
I can help you hit your goal quicker and it's yeah,
exactly what I say. No, you have a personal, bigger team, right?
Like saying like, okay,
we can get to this point 20% quicker or we don't work together.
Like that's incentive.
The other one is our relationships are more because once you build that trust,
like people are willing to like then spend time because they know that it's
worth it. So you get both. How much do you make as a PM?
How many hours do you a profile of a lot
YouTube questions on various in various areas.
I think the one thing good thing about being a PM is that you can get
good Dodge. We're going to give you, it's like, you can, you can make your own,
like you can work on things the way you want to work on it. Right. There's no,
like I need to ship this thing by this.
Or there might be an artificial deadline someplace that you work towards,
but it's essentially how you sequence that work.
And so there's no like routine day in some days,
it's like we have a deadline to hit.
We work really hard and other days it's more of like, okay,
we're just scoping out things like we have time and you can kind of relax.
And so I think it depends on the, just the project itself,
but it's also nice because like for other roles, like if you go to banking,
right, like you have a client that needs something before you even start on it.
And so you're working hard nonstop and they keep coming in,
whereas a PM you're managing your own team.
And so you can manage those deadlines and those timelines. So it's much easier.
I'm sorry. I didn't, I couldn't, I couldn't get the money.
You may give me a range so that they, it depends on what your range is just like
age or else I would say is less than a typical software
engineer. Okay. Um, Oh yeah. Actually that's good. I'd say less, I suppose,
software engineer, but it's con it's honorable software.
Did you think it was a very different,
your role as a product manager in box versus Facebook? Yes.
Like at night Maya was vastly different. I, in two things,
I think one it's like working in an enterprise company versus consumer and our
breasts company,
things are dictated more around like your customers that you're selling to.
So as much as much more clear about the things you need to build,
it's more about prioritization of how long it takes to build. Um,
and like what the cost is. Right?
Cause you only have a handful of clients or if you have like a box,
you have like 75,000 customers, bank customers.
But it's like at that point it's like an enterprise is pretty well with the
problems are, Oh yeah, I did.
They're pretty vocal because they're paying and they're paying.
And the goal is like, how do you unlock? Can you sell this deal?
So it's much easier to say like, here's like,
here's the top things that we need to do is closest to you and you figure it out
across all your customers, like what you do and you just execute and build.
It's tough because it's more, it's a little bit more technical type problems.
Um, and there's a lot more like there's a lot more stakeholders in it.
The interview process, like for PMs.
Maybe processes, it can go a couple of ways.
I think one at a company that's like big,
like Facebook or Google and those in New Jersey and you are interviewing for
like a general role, right? Like you're not integrated with the ski team.
It's pretty structured. It's like you like,
how well can you break down a product of brilliant ambiguous product problem?
Like for example, how do you build a better camera? Right?
Like it's just, that's, that's what would be like the prompt.
And you have to understand like how to break it down and put a framework in
place. Cool. The second one is how well you use data. It's like, okay,
this number is dropping. Like how would you debug it?
Or how would you set a goal.
Actually, before we go into data, can we just make it more concrete?
Maybe we can make an example. So how do you create a better camera?
So how would you answer that if you.
Yeah, I think the question is, is like,
I mean the way the structure you usually would take would be like, what is like,
you would start out like, Oh, what is the goal of the whole thing? Right?
Like what's the goal of the camera?
Like what's what are you trying to accomplish?
And then it's like potentially like setting like a metric,
like what does success for this camera look like?
Is it selling more as getting people to use more features? Right. Like, um,
and then I think it's totally all about like understanding who the users are,
who are the users and what are their needs, what are they looking for?
Is it like, if it's just like a basic point and shoot to capture memories,
like people don't care about quality.
They care about just the ease and quickness of like taking a photo cares about
like ridiculous quality. It's like, okay,
maybe it's something that's a very different. Right.
And then it's understanding like,
what are the features that help address those needs? So like,
what are the things that you would build?
And then it's all about understanding at that point. Like prioritization.
Like if you have a finite set of resources, how would you prioritize something?
Um, it's more of like,
how do you structure breakdown that point rather than what the question or the
problem.
Yeah. That's nice.
I feel like structure is really important in these interviews. For example,
when, when you asked me like, Oh, how do you make a camera better?
But then you start breaking down, like before, what you know,
is it for professionals or is it for, uh, like which, which audience.
Because the problem that people have all the time is they jumped straight to the
solution. It's like, Oh, the camera, like, uh,
the lens or it must be the quality, but there's no way to say like,
why are you already doing it?
Like you have to really know who your target audiences exactly.
And then make sure in the interview, you really ask them more questions. Right?
Yeah. You have to ask a lot of questions. That's like a conversation,
the exact cool. Awesome. And then the data side. Yeah.
It's more like, okay, you see numbers going down, like why? Or it's like, Oh,
you're setting a goal for your team. How would you set that goal?
And it's again, like, how do you put structure in place to, in order to like,
answer that question? Cause you could have ton of different goals, right?
Like if you're just a new product, like you might say,
it's all about user growth. If it's a more engaged, if it's more mature project,
it's all about like deepening engagement. Um,
and so there's like very different ways you can take it,
but it's all about putting a structure in place to say what the goal is nice.
Um, or what successes.
And then there's the other side of the other interviews that are outside of the
structured ones around like, okay, maybe you're getting hired for,
to be the first PM on a team or hire to a specific role at that point.
It's like,
it's a couple of things like how well you can still do break down ambiguous
problems, like potentially high while you can deal with data,
but also like doozies people want to work with you and do you have the right
experience to be like, to add value to their team?
And so it's a little bit more fundable if say like, okay,
maybe he's a little weaker on these places,
but like we would think we would work really well with him or we think his
perspective is really good. And so it just depends, I guess,
company to company enrolled role.
Hmm. How important is domain expertise usually for experienced PMs?
I think it depends on the company, like a company, like a big company.
You can kind of find any role. And so it's a little bit more generalized,
but for like a team that has one head count for 1:00 PM
at, for the rest of the year, it's like,
it's how do you make the right decision? And having domain expertise really,
really does help or really strong product Jewish and around like that specific
space. Um, so it definitely does help.
Do you think you might get pigeonholed though,
if it's always about domain expertise. Yeah.
Yeah. And you see that a lot. You see like some people who work in enterprise,
right? Like they stuck on, they don't, they're not stuck,
but they built the expertise around like building developer platforms and that's
just what they keep doing. Um,
but I think it is easy to escape and try something different.
And I think it's just sometimes easier to keep working in a role they worked in.
Cause you know, they understand the problem. Really.
Do you think you want to escape your domain or do you think you want to continue
in that domain? Whatever.
I actually don't know. I think it depends.
I think I work in media and I think media is super interesting.
It's also really challenging.
I think having from enterprise it's like it's a little bit more cut and dry in
terms of the things that you like and the things that you should build. Um,
and so it's just, it depends on like what type of environment you want.
I think in consumer it's a lot about like lock as well.
Cause it's hard to understand what people want. Um,
and so it's challenging if you're, you know, you have to just be patient.